hey guys and welcome back to the Le High
pen show joining me on the show today we
have the author of The
uncommunicated and podcast host on
iHeart radio and he's also a partner at
the Bitcoin opportunity fund Mark Moss
welcome back to the show how are you
yeah I'm uh I'm not welcome back to the
show it's my first time but I'm excited
to be here no we did we we did do we did
yeah okay we did so we I remember we not
officially like this right we we did a
virtual one but and I found that really
educational by the way and I really
enjoyed it so that's why I'm really
excited to have you here in person in
the studio yeah me too I'm glad it
worked out so what are you doing Yami
before we get into all of this before we
hear what Mark has to say I want to
bring you some good news from our
sponsors coinex coinex crypto exchange
has now rebranded its wallet via wallet
to coinex wallet this move signifies
coin X's commitment to the web through
space ensuring they stay ahead of the
curve and consistently offer the best to
their users as a Pioneer coinex wallet
is committed to solving difficult
industry problems and meeting the needs
of the users coinex wallet shuttle wants
to make far away a way by helping users
experience the magic of web 3 while
avoiding potential risks ensuring the
safety and growth of everyone coinex
wallet is your gateway to the future of
Finance with features like did identity
asset management for nfts and tokens
fast transactions with one click easy
swapping staking and authorization
detector for enhanced security the
wallet offers a seamless experience for
managing your crypto assets download now
to enjoy a range of crypto assets also
guys from Jan 12th to Jan 19th as long
as you download the coinx wallet app you
have a chance to share 5,000 C price
pull so what are you waiting for
download coinex wallet the link is in
the description below it's a Art Basel
week here in Miami um I didn't come last
year but I was here the year before so
it was pretty cool um
last time I was here I was at a party at
Michael sailor's house which is pretty
fun but this time value tment had a
party they're obviously kind of sort of
headquartered here in Miami I've been
kind of wanting to get into that camp I
got an invite so I was like well I'll
come out I know you wanted to sit down
and record I had a couple things that I
could do a little road show so I'm in
town for fun a little bit of work and
then I'm out of here that's the thing
with Miami it's just always buzzing
there's so much happening there's so
much going on with the Bitcoin space
crypto space content creation space um
that's what I love about it it's there's
always somebody coming and going you
know yeah I know and I'm in Southern
California and you would think La would
be sort of similar but it's not you
don't really have the influencers or
creators or whatever you want to call it
you certainly don't have sort of like
this Bitcoin crypto space um so it's
sort of dead out there surprisingly I
have a pretty nice Studio out there and
it's like hard to get people to come
down there for it so um it is a pretty
cool scene here would you move here no
why no I wouldn't move here Southern
California is a very unique place in the
world and because I grew up there I have
a very unique life that just most people
just don't have and so because of that
so I believe that um there's nowhere
that you can go to have it all so for me
I live on the beach like I'm three
houses off of the sand and I surf
multiple times a week um and then within
a two-hour drive I can be snowboarding
and so I snowboard all winter and then
right out of my house I can ride my
mountain bike cuz I have mountain range
that runs right next to the ocean so I
could ride my mountain bike in the
mountains and then I ride dirt bikes and
so on the weekends I can go out to the
desert we have all open deserts that I
can go ride my dirt bike um there's
nowhere in the world I can go do that I
certainly can't do any of that here in
Miami that's very true we all so I do
like it it's fun it's a it's a fun event
I come here a couple times a year
typically but I usually can't wait to
leave um right now right now the the
traffic is just atrocious and that's
coming from La so the traffic is really
bad um I love I love all the restaurants
I love all the water I like the people
but I mean I want to go home I get that
no I mean if you live you know just
three houses from the sand that's that's
incredible and I have a I have a ranch I
bought in Texas so just outside of
Austin Austin's a really cool City I
love the people there there's really
good group of content creators and all
the and Bitcoin Capital sort of there's
all that going on there as well but man
it's so cold in the winter it's so hot
in the summer there's like bugs
everywhere I can't mountain bike dirt
bike snowboard surf I can't do any of
that so it's like the quality of life is
almost the same well the quality of life
is better in California because I can do
those things as far as like the freedom
side of things like Gavin Newsome is
like the biggest slime ball in the world
and like California is gnarly like it's
not a good place to raise kids and all
that stuff but like my life is really my
day-to-day life is no different there
than it would be in Texas or or Florida
or whatever as far as like a freedom
level my standard of living would be
well my my cost of living is is more
expensive California is very expensive
um but like I don't optimize my life off
of like I I ate at a very expensive
Steakhouse last night I could have ate
at McDonald's right but I didn't do that
so uh my my cost of living is higher but
my standard of living is higher as well
yeah well that makes that makes sense um
you know I I think if if you're happy
where you are and everything's perfect
and your standard of living is and your
quality of life is amazing then why move
so the question that everybody wants to
know now um and I think it's the best
way to sort of introduce Bitcoin and the
podcast and everything like that is what
is going on in the market right now um
obviously we have the Haring about what
like six months I think even uh five
months away um you know the price is
pumping we saw yearly highs of
$44,000 so what is causing that pump
right now so let's just begin with price
there's a there's uh there's a lot of
things that I think are causing it so
let's start with the small stuff and
then we'll get to the bigger stuff so I
think from a small level there's a bunch
of different catalyst so one there's the
ETFs that are happening so you got Black
Rock like the large asset manager in the
world sort of a semi quasi arm of the
government so we saw like in 2020 they
worked with the government to like buy
stocks in the market um through these
Bank collapses we saw earlier in 2023
they work with the government to like
sort of help bail out the banks and
things like that so there's sort of like
this arm of the government and they're
launching a Bitcoin ETF which is a
pretty big deal for a bunch of reasons a
lot of people still think that bitcoin's
stupid magic internet money blah blah
blah when the largest asset manager in
the world doesn't see it that way the
largest asset manager in the world Larry
Fink was on CNBC 3 or four weeks ago now
now and he said that people are moving
to bitcoin as a flight to
safety and so if you think it's stupid
but the largest asset manager in the
world say people are flying to it to
safety like maybe you should recheck
yourself right success leaves Clues like
he's very successful so I think I think
there's that so the largest asset
manager in the world um in addition
there's about five or six others that
look like they could potentially go
through and so people think there's
going to be this massive demand for
Bitcoin when this goes through and and I
do as well I just made a video saying
that there's a warning in this though
and so I'll break that down for for you
uh but there's this there's this big
push and one it uh 72% of financial
advisers said they would recommend
Bitcoin and crypto if an ETF was
approved oh wow so just think about that
right so there's going to be a massive
long-term man demand and so everyone's
trying to sort of front run this news so
I think that's that's Catalyst number
one um Catalyst number two is is you
mentioned the having cycle so about
every four years the supply the new
supply of Bitcoin gets cut in half and
so while financial markets can be very
complex they're actually very simple all
price moves on supply and demand so if
the demand stays the same but the supply
gets cut in half then the price goes up
but if the demand goes up with ETFs Etc
and then the supply gets cut in half
then it's obviously very dramatic so I
think that's another Catalyst and so if
you look at sort of the price chart of
Bitcoin over a you know 7 eight 10 year
period um on a log scale you can see it
move in these uh these fouryear cycles
and so that's sort of where we're at so
I think that's the other Catalyst but
then I think there's a bigger Catalyst
and and this is a bigger Catalyst not
just for Bitcoin it's for assets and
it's also for fiat currency and that
trend is that we are witnessing I I just
spoke at Bitcoin conference in Amsterdam
and the title of my talk was the end of
the international monetary order okay so
what does that mean um everyone says
like the dollar is going to die end of
the dollar the Brick's going to replace
the dollar blah blah blah no it's not
just the dollar we're witnessing the end
of fiat currency the international
monetary order the system that we've had
for 50 years or really whatever 100
years since Breton Woods um that's
ending and so what do I mean by that
we're in a 50-year experiment of fiat
currency so gold had been money for th
thousands 5,000 years in 1971 we broke
the tie to gold and so we've been in
this now what 51 52 years of floating
fiat currency paper money and it's it's
an experiment and it's gone horribly
wrong and it's starting to fall apart
and so what we're seeing globally and
people are just starting to wake up to
this the I hate to use the word the
global Elites but you know the
sovereigns the the people pulling the
strings they've been buying up hard
assets as fast as they can for the last
year China's bought half of the lithium
mines in the world you have the OPEC
country Saudi Arabia Russia saying we're
going to pump less oil because we'd
rather have the oil in the ground GM
Motors the largest aible manufacturer in
the US said that they they spent $650
million on a lithium mine again they'd
rather have the minerals everyone wants
to buy hard assets they don't want us
treasuries they don't want paper dollars
anymore and so we're witnessing uh a
small scale ETF boom on a larger scale
the for your having cycle but really
what we're seeing globally is everyone's
moving to hard assets which is why even
though the fed's gone on this fast rate
hiking cycle even though recession 2024
well 2023 never came 2024 whatever like
home prices aren't dropping stock prices
aren't dropping as a matter of fact
asset prices keep going up and that's
because people don't want to hold paper
dollars and why don't they want to hold
paper dollars well they don't want to
hold paper dollars because um so you
have sort of two well there's several
camps of Economics but let's just divide
them into two you sort of have like this
kenian economic Camp which is basically
we just print money modern monetary
Theory mmt and then you have sort of
like this Austrian School of Economics
which believes in like um basically
sound monetary principles right and in
that camp sort of The Godfather is lwi
Von misus and he wrote something called
the crackup boom and it starts out by
saying and then suddenly the people
realize that inflation is both permanent
and intentional yeah and once that
happens they start to lose trust I don't
know the rest all off top my head but
they lose trust in the currency and then
they want to get out of it as fast as
they can into whatever they can and so
if you look at Venezuela Lebanon turkey
Etc they don't want to hold that Turkish
ler they don't want to hold you know
that those types of currencies and
they're trying to get out as fast they
can and it's happening all over the
world the dollar is still the best
currency in the world but it's also
happening to the US dollar as well the
world realizes now that inflation is
intentional mhm and it's permanent so
just since 2019 the government the the
US Treasury has increased their spending
by 50% 50% they bring in about uh 4 four
4.5 trillion dollar of income and spend
about $6.5 trillion dollar 2 trillion
50% of their budget is printed every
single year and that's up 50% just from
where it was a couple years ago and so
that's why gas is up and homes are up
and steak and milk is up by 50% and so
people realize this now um now if you've
noticed on mainstream media the Biden
Administration the White House kgp Etc
they're like putting out even news
headlines saying saying inflation's not
because of money printing they're like
trying to Gaslight us but they
understand it's a problem which is why
they're saying that no you have it wrong
inflation is not because we did this no
no no people know but they're also
saying that inflation is is coming down
they're also saying that right um so
they're saying both right and I did a
video in January and I said the pivot
here and what do I mean by that the
pivot the the treasury or or sorry the
FED has been on this um path trying to
bring inflation down as measured by the
CPI Consumer Price Index and I made a
video in January because in January the
BLS Bureau of Labor Statistics which is
the one that makes up the CPI basket
changed the calculation of the basket
now they've changed the the calculation
many times but in January they made a
change and instead of taking a two-year
comp or a comparison over two years
they'd moved to a one-year comp the
reason why that's important to
understand is because inflation is
measured year over-year last December to
this December and so in January I said
based off of where the numbers were last
year this is what this year would look
like if nothing else changes and I said
if no inflation changes by September
we'll be at 3% and we were and it wasn't
cuz I have this magic ball it was just
math it's like hey if you compare off of
last year because last year we were at
9% so when we're at the highest point
ever of course it's going to look lower
so I think there's there's part of that
but also there's just massive amount of
lying so like let's just look at the
last CPI rating um um numbers that came
out for example they said that um health
insurance costs went down by 32
% where where did that happen my monthly
insurance bill didn't go down did yours
no I mean the cost at the hospital or so
like where did they come up with that
yeah but yet they threw that out there
right another thing they they use that's
very shady is that um they don't use
home prices home prices are known we
have the MLS they're in a database we
have um all types of data on that but
they don't use home prices to to figure
out what home prices are or what they
consider a shelter in the basket they
use a owner's equivalent rent how do
they determine that number through phone
surveys well I ain't answering no phone
survey are you no no no one is who the
hell is answering a phone survey right
so nobody so they have like almost no
sample sizes no one's getting any
accurate data and so to put this into
comparison we can look at like rent.com
tracks the rent prices year to year and
this is like actually off of data from
like actual leases that get signed but
the BLS doesn't use that and so they go
after the the survey type data and they
said that there was like a 0.2% increase
in when we know rents like doubled and
the reason why that's important is that
rent that shelter part of the CPI basket
makes up 30% of that basket so anyway uh
one they changed the calculation two
it's completely lies um but what they're
doing and this sets up a bigger thing
but what they're doing is they're giving
themselves cover to be able to start
easing again which is why in January
when that said when that happened I said
the pivots here they're giving
themselves the cover because they you
know they have to win the war on
inflation so they just changed the
calculation hey congratulations we won
now we can go back into easing again
because the US Treasury is going to go
bankrupt if we don't start easing again
um and then we when will that happen
well I mean they're technically already
bankrupt but like um we're we're kind of
going closer closer closer like this I I
can break that math down for you um but
real quick um so one by changing the
calculation we bring CPI down and two
with Wars now we have an excuse for
inflation so either way the FED sort of
has this cover they need to kind of go
back and pivot without losing
credibility that's insane when when do
you think the printing will
start well so first of all the printing
is sort of like uh that that's not
really how it works we talk about the
FED printing money the FED doesn't print
money the the banks print money so when
the banks issue loans then then money is
printed um right now lending has been
going down because there's not as much
appetite for it the banks haven't been
wanting to do as much but as far as like
the fed's policy as easing so we
consider them going from QE quantity
easing to QT quantitative tightening
tight easing would be buying treasuries
tightening is selling off treasuries as
well as tightening the market by raising
the price of money if I sell iPhones for
$1,000 and all of a sudden I say hey I'm
going to sell iPhones for 200 bucks for
the next week do I sell more iPhones or
less more yeah right if they went from
1,200 I sell more right um and so when I
lower the price of money people borrow
borrow more as well if I say hey money
is 8% and now hey you can get as much
money as you want for 1% a lot of people
go get it and so when they raise the
price of money they tighten it people
get less of that right um and so the
question is is when will they go back
into an easing well I think they already
have so we saw um in March of 2023 the
banks collapsed within 6 days the FED
set up a facility called the btfp the
bank term funding facility and that $100
billion doar went out to the banks
that's printing money I mean that's what
we call it it's technically something
different but that's easing if you will
right um now the FED um the last
treasure auction so the fed or the
treasury is spending so much money
there's not enough buyers for that debt
right now and so the last 30-year
auction that we had had massive what we
call dysfunction there weren't enough
buyers for the amount of treasuries they
were trying to sell and so the F the the
FED trying to tighten can no longer sell
their treasuries when the US Treasury
doesn't even have enough buyers so that
so we're there like like that's the
problem and so what happened because
there weren't enough buyers the price of
those treasur went up or I should say
the yield the treasury has to offer went
up it's what we call a TA they wanted to
pay this by the end of the auction they
had to pay this and was the worst one
we've seen in over 50 years so it's a
it's a really big deal so I think we're
pretty much already there I expect um at
this next fmoc meeting the FED meeting
next month it'll be December 13th I
believe um I expect the FED to sort of
formally announce the
pause um I don't uh a pivot might be
considered when they actually because
they've been tightening or raising rates
a pivot would be when they stop raising
and go back to lowering I think they'll
pause which means hold them for a while
and then start to lower them I think
they're going to continue to hold them
high for a while because they need
credibility if they lower if they pivot
and lower right away they're going to
look bad so what they'll do is they'll
probably pause but they'll be injecting
liquidity so it's like a stealth QB so
so they look like they're doing
something good even though they're not
um but we can chart where the market
thinks where they're pricing in these
cuts to be and it's pretty much looks
like probably by March or April of next
year they'll be actually cutting rates
so I think we sort of have this about
120-day window where asset prices could
really move really fast and I want to
just go back a sec to um you know
Bitcoin specifically and and the harving
um because everything that we're talking
about is going to affect the price of
Bitcoin um and right now we we think
that you know Bitcoin has these fouryear
Cycles well historically speaking it
does according to to the Haring but with
everything that you're talking about and
you know the the Bitcoin spot ETF that's
potentially coming how do you think
that's going to affect bitcoin's
fouryear Cycles do you think this is the
last fouryear cycle H how do you how do
you see it going in the future so first
thing I would say is that um Bitcoin is
the most price sensitive asset that we
have because of the low liquidity that
we have and so it moves in advance of
other markets and so this is why this
important to understand so I think
Bitcoin is sniffing this out before
other assets are the other assets will
catch up and so what do I mean by that
um the FED had been lowering rates
keeping them low doing all this easing
right in November of
2021 the FED made a statement that they
were going to Pivot and start tightening
the market they didn't actually do
anything until I believe February
January February of the next year so the
FED doesn't want to scare markets they
don't want to surprise them they try to
tell them months in advance what they're
going to do as soon as they announced it
Bitcoin started selling off November
2021 was the top yeah a few weeks later
I think it was two to three weeks later
the NASDAQ which is the tech stock they
started selling off so the more risk the
asset is the faster it will move so
Bitcoin started selling off first
Bitcoin realized the Fed was going to
tighten first then NASDAQ the S&P didn't
start selling off for a few months later
and so now we see Bitcoin going up first
right then the NASDAQ the tech stock
start to follow and then the S&P 500 so
I think it's important to understand
that now in light of the four-year cycle
we just talked about what was
interesting when Bitcoin started selling
off in these fouryear Cycles
Bitcoin makes a t a top an all-time high
at about 18 months past the having cycle
which put it right at November of
2021 now because we haven't had that
many of them yet we're going on the
fourth one it's not like empirical
evidence it's not like 50 years or 500
years of data right it's like we've had
a couple and I sort of kind of got
caught up like a lot of people did in
like well the buyers of Bitcoin have
changed and we have long-term holders
and we have institutions now and public
companies and public companies aren't
going to be forced to sell so they're
going to hold and Michael sailor's on TV
saying that all your Cycles are broken
and we also expected the top of Bitcoin
in that last cycle to be much higher
150,000 or whatever so as we're getting
to November of 2021 which we knew 18
months later was going to be the top but
it was like in the 60s and we're like no
this can't be it the Cycles are broken
it's going to be much higher this time
it's not right but it was so it's pretty
interesting
um yeah so I don't know did what was no
I'm just trying to figure out just like
how correlated Bitcoin is because people
talk about Bitcoin being this
uncorrelated
asset what right um it's correlated to
liquidity okay so if you look at um the
money supply is measured in what's
called M2 if you look at M2 in the
United States it's been going down the
money supply has been going down but if
you look at Global M2 it's been going up
to the roof and so if you look overlay a
chart of Bitcoin and Global M2 they move
almost together um so because like I
said Bitcoin really starts to sniff that
out as far as correlation to other
assets um it moves sometimes it becomes
more correlated sometimes it becomes
less correlated the Global Financial
system is very correlated in a sense
because it all moves on liquidity so
when liquidity drops down people start
selling assets MH okay well not just in
terms of um liquidity but what about
just geopolitically and everything
that's going on right now because I I
know a lot of people um didn't expect
this pump just because of everything
that we're seeing globally with Wars
what's happening in the Middle East
America have said that they can fund
both Wars in Europe and the Middle East
um so people were actually putting their
money out they weren't expecting the
pump and obviously that wasn't quite the
case people that pulled their money out
don't understand how things work so like
I said the the global Elites around the
world they've been moving to hard assets
while they're telling you fear fear fear
crash crash crash and everyone goes to
cash they're buying up all the assets so
they understand it um and I would say
people that pulled their their money out
because of hey we're going to fight two
Wars they didn't really understand what
that means so if the governments are
already broke if the government's
already borrowing 50% of their budget
and then they're going to spend more for
Wars where are they going to get that
money well they're going to have to
borrow even more and that creates even
more in that means the money spat to
expand even more and the bigger the
deficit is the more they have to borrow
which means the more has to be pumped
the more that they pump then the more
inflation they have right so I think
people just didn't understand that
Dynamic probably which is what we're
seeing play out exactly right now and I
think both back to uh LED vesus um
inflation being both permanent and
intentional so intentional meaning do
you think the governments are going to
spend less money in the future like of
course the answer is no and then um do
you think inflation will be less in the
future well not if they don't qu stop
spending but also what we have on top of
that remember prices are uh equilibrium
of supply and demand so there's many
many there's a million reasons there's a
trillion reasons why prices could move
so when they increase the money supply
you have more demand than there is
Supply but what about if you cut Supply
as well so for example in war Supply
chains break down right so now you have
increased money supply because of the
war more money printing but then you
also have goods and services dropping
Supply dropping because of demand or uh
Supply chains dropping um now we since
really um probably really since the
pandemic but probably more since the
Russia Ukraine invasion you have um
basically this world breaking apart and
now like the United States is on a
massive mission to reshore supply chains
right so now we want to build microchips
in the US we want to build everything in
the US and every nation is doing that as
well and so that means that inflation
goes up prices went down for the last 50
years because of globalization so we
took jobs for 50 bucks in the US and
sent them overseas for eight bucks we
took a $100 part here made it for eight
bucks in China but now that's reversing
now the $8 part is coming back to be 100
bucks now that job is coming back and so
this trend that we've seen for 50 years
of prices going down is reversing and
now we'll start to see prices going up
at the same time as we're seeing massive
money Printing and so I think there's a
massive massive massive move towards
inflation in the future
so this seems like the perfect
opportunity to introduce Bitcoin and and
sort of understand how does Bitcoin
solve these problems you know people
refer to bitcoin as a lot of different
things like digital gold a hedge against
inflation a medium of exchange all these
different things but to you what's the
most important use case for Bitcoin well
I think there's one other big important
use case and I think we'll put these
together so one we have this um rise of
inflation spending governments are
continuing to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and they want to spend more and
more money we've talked about that but
the second piece part of back to them
getting bigger and bigger and bigger is
the rise of authoritarianism okay right
and so back to do you think governments
will print more money or less money in
the future more do you think governments
will decide to give us more of our
freedom back in the future probably not
right and so um that's the second
benefit of what Bitcoin does and so
authoritarians want control and the best
thing that they want to control the main
thing they want to control is money um
Henry Kissinger who just died I don't
want to say Ro rip it's more like good
rid to that guy probably the biggest war
criminal in the world but he said
control the food control the people
control the energy control The Continent
Control the control the go back control
energy control the continent oh the
continent yeah control the money control
the world yeah so those are the attack
vectors food right so we see the attack
on our food in the United States our
food is horrible they're trying to shut
down cows in California the restaurants
have to pay a 30% tax on pork oh I
didn't know that porks fart too much and
then methane and whatever right so it's
like they're attacking the food they're
trying to shut down the farmers in the
Netherlands Etc right so there's an
attack on food um then there's attack on
energy control the energy right and now
the money so they want to control the
money that's the last piece and so they
want to see every single transaction you
know in the United States if any
transaction under six over 600 bucks
they want to like turn you upside down
and Shine the flashlight in there and
see what's going on never mind the
billions of dollars were sent into
Palestine or Israel or whatever right um
so they want to control that money they
want to not just see everything they
want to be able to control everything so
um you know in North Korea in
Afghanistan these are extreme examples
but in North Korea you can't even really
have money right they want to see
everything in Afghanistan the Taliban
controls the bank so you can't even send
women money there for example right um
and so we have this rise of
authoritarianism two billion people in
the world have no access to banking
because they don't have permission to
join the banking system and so Bitcoin
fixes that as well so if I if I if I put
these together and sort of frame it up
and I put this in my talk in Bitcoin
Amsterdam Solutions come to
problems entrepreneurs solve problem s
we look at a problem in the world we
come up with a solution so what are the
big problems that we have one we have
endless money printing the problem is
that man humans not to be sexist here
but humans have you know human nature
and emotions and we have greed and no
human will without that has the ability
to print money is not going to use that
right so like they're always going to do
this every time we've seen Zimbabwe
throw their currency away and restart it
three times but they do the same thing
every time because it's just human
nature so this in the money in this
money printing that can't be solved with
humans we that's a big problem so a
solution would be to go to something
with a fixed Supply cap we have another
problem we have uh we have a problem
with permission two billion adults in
the world can't get access to banking I
believe like the smartphone is the great
equalizer um I mean look what you do
with your career how much money you make
with just like kind of your phone and
kind of this what you're doing right
here if you can get onto YouTube and
learn anything and you get on to social
media meet anybody and you could deliver
services like any kid in the world could
make six figures online
but not if you're not allowed to join
the banking system if you just happen to
be a 14-year-old kid from Iran like
sorry no banking system for you right so
if the banking system is permissioned
and that's a problem then we need
permissionless right if um we have a
problem with author authoritarians
trying to censor transactions we need
something that's censorship resistant
and so that's what Bitcoin has it has
all of those attributes right that's the
utility that it gives us and I think
part of what we see in the United States
we talk about the ET fs and things like
that that's sort of like a local US
problem but if we look globally there's
a massive demand for permissionless and
censorship resistant money yeah
definitely but what always strikes me
and we spoke about this actually last
time when you on the podcast is what
happens if they turn off the internet
because I think it's very possible um
you know not necessarily even turn off
the internet but but you know control
what we can and can't do um you know in
Dubai for example you can't use certain
uh sites they're just simply blocked I
think like Zoom for example is blocked
um so what what do we do in a situation
whereby these um authoritarian Elites or
whoever they are turn off the internet
that makes your Bitcoin worthless
doesn't it yeah and there's there is
precedence for that so in Egypt during
the um during the uh Arab Spring they
had uh Egypt shut off the internet so
typically most countries have one or two
cables that they could just cut off and
shut themselves off I think the United
States has three I think there's one in
Los Angeles one in DC and maybe one in
New York and so they could just shut
that off but think about that like would
they want to shut off the internet maybe
I mean well it's it's a it's a
double-edged sword right and so this is
this is what authoritarians have to
Grapple with either one I can take away
all Freedom no internet no communication
no whatever so I can maintain power if I
do that my country is going to have no
economic activity we're going to have no
inventions we're going to have no
industry we have nothing so we're in the
Dark Ages MH if I give them access to
the tools then can have massive
abundance but how do I control it so
they're stuck in this conundrum or
dilemma if you would call it that right
um North Korea has gone to one extreme
end and look how bad things are in North
Korea you have North Korea and South
Korea from Night At Night you can see a
picture in South Korea is lit up and
North Korea is dark right the average
person is shorter in North Korea the
lifespan of people is is less in North
Korea they have no economic growth they
have no invention but in South Korea
they create TVs and all kinds of
electronics and their flourishing right
and that's because of the amount of
Freedom they have so they could take
away the internet and take away all that
but then they kind of shoot themselves
in the foot so they're trying to like
play Both Sides which is why in Dubai or
China they give you the internet but
they sort of only give you the features
they want you to have exactly now how
would Bitcoin work in that environment
so I just think that the chance of
having no internet is very low okay they
could certainly censor it like they do
in China and Dubai I just don't see how
they would want to go full North Korea
okay like what nation would so I think
that attack Vector isn't super super
there now now um if they were to start
cutting off the internet I mean that
could certainly change things for sure
but of course now we have satellite
internet right so we could just get
internet via starlink um but then that
requires but then you're trusting in one
centralized entity for Bitcoin to work
starlink uh well yes and no right so
that just relays signals so let's just
say that the US decides to cut off the
internet um great so then we have Game
Theory do you think El Salvador is going
to cut off the internet do you think
that Argentina do you think that Peru do
you think that Australia do you think
right on on but what do we do living in
the US if they were to cut off the
internet cuz obviously we're don't in El
Salvador I mean I think this is a very
extreme hypothetical hypothetical
example don't think it's that extreme I
mean if whatever I mean you're talking
about the us but if whatever country
you're living and decided to cut off the
internet
completely you could move people people
flee I heard you on Peter Schiff talking
to Peter shiff and you said people were
fleeing you know Ukraine but they
couldn't carry the gold with them right
so people flee this is what happens
people flee these nations they left
South Africa they leave Iran they leave
whatever they leave Russia right so I
think you leave yeah I think that that's
the easy answer I just don't see that as
the biggest attack Vector but I do see a
major Massive Attack Vector on the
censorship of the internet so for
example in the United States I think it
was 26 high-ranking members of
government Senators congressmen signed
an order called the restrict act and
it's against it's a Tik Tock bill right
but really it's not about Tik Tock at
all as a matter of fact if you dig into
it it says that any piece of technology
that they deem to be a threat to
National security could be made illegal
right and so now today everything's a
threat to National Security like if you
seow seeds of whatever misinformation
disinformation if you say something that
um you know messes with the trust or
what The Narrative of the government is
trying to pass they could say that's a
threat to National Security so
potentially they could say Bitcoin is
being used to fund terrorism it's a
threat to National Security and they
could make it illegal so we know they
can't shut it down as a matter of fact
yesterday Jamie Diamond from JP Morgan
said uh if I was the government I would
shut it down
it's like well you can't they could say
we'll kill you if we catch you with it
they could say that right they could say
it's illegal and so in this restrict act
you would face 20 years in prison a loss
of all your property and a million
dollar fine like not even like murderer
doesn't even get that like that's insane
right so they could do that and that
would probably deter a lot of people
from using it but they can't stop it so
it would still be usable even in that
instance right um the question would
just be that I think that technology is
outpacing the government and this is
sort of an interesting thing I won't go
deep into this unless you want to dig
into
but technology is what changes the world
when you go look through thousands of
years of History it changes the world in
in a lot of ways but a couple core ways
is it changes the way that we
communicate which then changes the way
that we organize so it changes the
structure of our civilization the
structure of our government so let me
give a couple examples in about a
thousand um the year 1080 um there was a
new piece of technology in the Europe in
in Europe it had been around in Asia
before but in Europe and it was called a
stirrup like a horse Stirrup and that
allowed a knight to get up onto a horse
in full armor and to be able to fight
from the horse now Egyptians had fought
with horses they used chariots the
Romans used horses but they would get
off the horse to fight now they could
fight on a horse that allowed one Knight
to to handle hundreds of surfs at a time
and that balance of power shifting like
that um led to the feudal system being
created so a very centralized form of
government where you had King the
knights and then the peasants surf down
at the bottom so
technology changed and created a new
form of civilization and governments now
fast forward 500 years 1500 we had a new
technological Revolution called
gunpowder and it's known as the
gunpowder Revolution and now a surf with
a gun could take out hundreds of knights
and the feudal system fell apart and we
went back to a decentralized system
where now you had farms and Cottages
then we had the Industrial Revolution
which then brought everybody into cities
and factories working for big
corporations and this is where it gets
interesting so in the in 1908 was the
fourth Industrial Revolution and that
was the invention of um the car the
automobile gas and oil but also mass
production so now everybody started
working in factories and this is really
what what was one of the biggest
contributors to this growing middle
class we always hear about the middle
class has been hollowed out and it's
because they shipped all our jobs to
China blah blah blah that's part of it
but the big piece is that in this
Industrial revolution in this mass
production everyone worked on assembly
line and even though you may be way
smarter than me if we're on the assembly
line together we do the same job so dumb
people and smart people all the same so
we had this massive middle class now
when I have this Mass manufacturing I
have to come up with a new management
system to manage the masses like cogs in
a wheel and then we have mass Management
on mass corporations and we created a
government structure to manage that but
the type of government we have today is
no longer compatible with the world that
we live in and this is the big problem
that we're seeing and so if you if you
kind of keep that frame in mind and then
you sort of move forward you look at the
government trying to sort of maintain
their grasp on a system that's that's
that's just gone they they've been
replaced it's no longer there and it's
this technology that's changing it so
now we have this decentralized
technology and they can just no longer
control it and I think what happens is
the more they try to control things the
more irrelevant and incompetent they
look so for example in Europe right now
they're trying to pass laws where you
can't custody your own Bitcoin yeah
right and Elizabeth Warren's floating
that here in the US so they're going to
make it illegal for me to know 12 words
in my head right so you can't know words
anymore yeah like what does that even
mean yeah I mean I think um I think yeah
it's ridiculous I think the the EU also
would like people to screenshot
literally screenshot um their
non-custodial wallets you know as proof
that they have them so you know I don't
know how how you would pleas that I
understand that they're going to P the
on andof ramps um and they've already
done that with the likes of crypto.com
for example now you have to actually if
you want to send money from a non uh uh
non kyc wallet non-custodial wallet to
The Exchange you have to say whe whether
that's your wallet so you have to kyc
that that non-custodial wallet yeah it's
pretty weird really yeah and and then
like I I mean not that you know I would
ever lie but I don't know what happens
if you do lie like I don't I don't know
whether like they know and they'll be
like uhuh wrong answer like money is now
Frozen you know what I mean the problem
is that we're trying to we're trying to
move into a new world and we're trying
to use old world rules and those two are
no longer compatible Jeff Booth would
say that it's hard to imagine this new
world when we're stuck in the world that
we're in so for example I was working on
a project in El Salvador and I was
taking jobs down to El Salvador and I
was I actually brought phones smart
phones down and I gave them out to these
people and they were able to download an
app and do jobs on the app and get paid
in SATs and in order to so I gave I
brought 10 phones with me I gave 10
phones out and they were able to just
log in yeah they didn't put any ID in
there there was no name there was no
social security number there wasn't even
a username what were they logging into
though this app it was an app which app
was it the El Salvador app uh wasn't the
shivo is it no no no it was an app to do
work it was a workout no it was a
workout so they can do jobs on the phone
data entry jobs what's called like
microtask no no this is a job so they on
the phone it had the app they would do
the jobs and they would get paid in SATs
all they had to do is put their Bitcoin
address in there and they would receive
SATs now in El Salvador they can go
spend those SATs anywhere they want they
can go to McDonald's or Starbucks or the
papusa stand or the or the whatever they
want right and so they've received
they've received payment in Bitcoin with
no kyc their name is not in the system
anywhere and then they can go spend the
Bitcoin so you talked about the choke
point being the on andof ramps but what
about when there is no on andof ramps
what about when I've been paid in
Bitcoin and I spend in Bitcoin then what
and so that's the new model and that's
where El Salvador is already at um I'm
sure you know I know lots of people who
live 100% on on this Bitcoin standard
and um you know when you look at sort of
look at uh more in your age range if you
look at like these Millennials you see
videos every day popping up from like
people in Canada and whatever like they
can't afford to live yes insane they
have no money they're broke they have no
future they can't afford to buy a house
they have no stocks right they don't
have any money so going back to the on
andof ramps haha what are you going to
do to me I got no money anyway screw you
I'll just get paid in Bitcoin right and
so we have this whole new generation
that's coming up who isn't there's no
attack Vector from the state for them
what is the state going to do take their
money they don't have any money right
I'll just get paid in Bitcoin and I'll
just spend in Bitcoin and screw you
right yeah especially with that just
being more and more tech companies that
are actually willing to pay in Bitcoin
yeah um and then and then back to the
game theory so if they want to go down
to El Salvador they can just get paid in
Bitcoin yeah and what is Game Theory
game theory is um who moves first you
ever play the game of musical chairs
when you were a kid yeah right so the
Music Stops and there's like Game Theory
so the game theory is like the us could
say hey no Bitcoin for us like we're not
going to do it but if the other nations
adopt bit uh adopt that the game theory
says their first move or Advantage would
give them Advantage let me give you some
historical examples of this so um lots
of things had been money throughout
history um silver was actually one of
the main forms of money in the 1400s
1500s um when Spain was like the
superpower they discovered huge silver
deposits in Peru um China had massive
stor holds of silver but what happened
in the late 1800s is everybody started
moving to the gold standard and everyone
starts switching gold gold gold gold
gold China's like I'm not switching to
Gold we're we got silver screw you guys
right game theory so what happened is
China decided not to move to Gold when
the rest of the world did and because
they were the last one finally they had
lost so much value in their silver they
had lost so much power they lost their
position in the world and finally had to
capitulate and say fine we'll move to
gold and so that's sort of like Game
Theory like being this last mover okay
interesting um speaking of you know uh
technology and Innovations and all of
that one interesting thing that's
happened this year is ordinals um and we
spoke yesterday a little bit about that
but I do want to get your take on it um
because it's kind of the question that
everyone's asking everyone at the moment
you know if you're if you believe in
Bitcoin you believe in um free market
capitalism what's your take on ordinals
and for me personally I'm very much um a
free market capitalist and if that's
what the network decides then and and
the people decide then so be it um but I
know not everybody holds that opinion so
are you pro- ordinals or are you anti-
ordinals Mark I think I I would say let
the market figure it out um as of right
now I don't really see a really good
Market fit for that I think it's a
little bit ridiculous what we've seen so
far and so I don't see that people would
want to pay a lot of money for that and
so I think it start of maybe Falls away
maybe maybe they find a really cool case
for it and and and it succeeds in the
market so I think we'll have to see how
it goes the reason why I would say let
the market figure it out is because what
we already saw was when you start doing
upgrades on the base layer it leads to
unintended consequences and so now when
we did the upgrade on tap rout now we've
enabled ordinals and now people don't
like ordinal so now they want to go back
to the base layer and tamper with it
again but what else happens after that
now I'm not the most qualified person
I'm not a I'm not a Bitcoin core
developer so I'll admit that but I am
smart enough to maybe see pattern
recognition and when you made a change
it created unintended consequence you
don't want so you want to go back and
make another change but what other
consequence could be made at that point
right unintended consequence I guess
would be made so I don't know and so
what I would say is just let the market
figure it out at this point I think you
know some of the first use cases that
we've seen such as um you know these
nfts if you will right very very poor
versions of of Graphics it it seems very
stupid to me um certainly you know under
the
belief that all value is subjective so
maybe there's value to somebody else I
don't think there was value in that but
that's not for me to decide um but I
think that was sort of like testing out
gimmicky we'll see how it goes I I have
seen other things that make me a little
bit more optimistic such as like the
Bitcoin conference in Amsterdam um Julie
nange from Wikileaks they set up a
website where they're taking all of the
Wikileaks and putting them into the
bigin blockchain so all of that data
leak that has cost Julian Assange
basically his life is now being record
recorded in these ordinals in the in it
so so like okay I guess that's pretty
good I mean does that need to be done
probably not because the internet is
already pretty decentralized anyway so
like for example maybe you're not old
enough to remember but we had like uh
you know Napster back in the day which
then led to like um all types of file
sharing right and so you could like
download music and download movies and
stuff and like it's like little bits of
data stored around everyone's computers
and like that's pretty sensorship
resistant so like Wikileaks could just
be on that now that takes people to seed
it and so if nobody seeds it you can't
download it so there's problems within
that um but I don't know if the Bitcoin
blockchain is the best place for it but
it seems like a pretty good place for
because I know it's CP resistant uh the
Bible people have risked their life
forever sneaking Bibles in and out of
communist countries and now it can just
be on the blockchain 3D gun schematics
right if they want to take away our guns
then we can just get the gun schematics
and print them so I think there's some
good examples of why we would need
censorship resistant information there's
a movie made called uh well it's a book
it's a book written and then there was a
movie made about it uh Fahrenheit 451
okay and the premise of the book is
that um there was a Another World War
the world got destroyed because there
was too much information and people
couldn't agree there was two voices and
those two different camps went to war
with each other sounds kind of familiar
so what they decided to do is get rid of
every piece of information and the
government would be the single source of
Truth yeah and that way they could
prevent any other type of thing sounds
very familiar so then they you had these
groups of people that were protecting
the books and these people would not
only they' have huge libraries of actual
books but they' commit them to Memory
right um and then there was the the the
firemen were actually going and burning
the books anyway interesting book um
there's a movie about it too uh but
anyway uh you know so when you think
about that type of environment like
there is certain information that we
need to protect we need to preserve like
the Bible or gun schematics or whatever
Wikileaks or whatever so it seems like
it's a pretty good place to store it I
suppose um I don't see a really good use
case for it that seems interesting to me
I don't know if that's the best place to
do that but yeah let the market figure
it out but why are people so anti-
ordinals what's the problem with that
other than stupid nfts that you know
they don't like I think that's that's
that's that's case number one I think
case number two is that it pushes up the
transaction cost right so the block
space so Satoshi Nakamoto actually gave
us two inventions multiple inventions
but two digital scarcities so for the
first time in history we have something
digitally scarce and when I say
digitally scarce me
meaning um with you know most digital
files if you take a picture on your
phone sent to me I can send that to as
many people as I want so it's not
digital scarcity so Bitcoin created that
uh digital scarcity 21 million Bitcoin
but what he also created was um finite
block space so about every 10 minutes a
new block is um transacted and it has
the transactions in there and there's
only so much space that can be in there
so that that's a finite amount so then
there's a bid for that and so whoever
bids the highest gets that block space
and so if ordinals take up that space if
a if a nft does then it pushes the price
up for my transaction to send money for
example right so then they would say oh
it's wasting block space it's out
competing valid transactions or or more
important transactions but I would say
the more more important transaction is
the one that's willing to pay the most
yeah right so I think that's probably
why they're up in arms over it I think
one you know they just think it's stupid
two they say it's you know crowding out
or out competing Financial transactions
and I think I would say the third final
reason probably and this is sort of more
my reason is that sort of my thing
against ordinals nfts and crypto just in
general is because I come up from a very
Freedom maximalist um Viewpoint where
you know you look at Libertarians and
all these people who scream at the wind
and want to change the world but they
have no way to do that and if you
realize that the source of all the power
of these authoritarians and governments
the we and all these people come from
the ability to print money MH so so
really the only tool that we have is if
we can take out the money printer like
that's the attack vector and there's one
tool to do that that's Bitcoin right
Bitcoin can do that um and so I look at
it from a very strong Freedom Viewpoint
this is the tool that we have to win and
what happens is when you start talking
about all these other crypto projects it
dilutes the message and it confuses most
people most people just aren't as
they're not as big of a nerd as I am
right they're not down this Rabbit Hole
so they don't really understand the
differences and they're like what do you
mean cardano's look how much money I
made and it's like we're not in for this
for the same reason I'm not here for as
much money as I can make I'm trying to
change the world with a tool and so I
think it starts to dilute the message
and people don't realize like the power
that Bitcoin has and what we can
actually do with it and I think for me
that's probably like my most important
thing is just trying to keep that
message
pure so well speaking of the message um
and understanding that you know the base
layer has has been upgraded and and
things are moving on and things are
changing where do you see bitcoin's role
in society so do you see it as you know
us moving onto a Bitcoin standard um
Bitcoin being This Global medium of
exchange um or simply you know just
digital gold and a store of value like
where do you see like what is
hyperbitcoinization to you so I would
say that there's an evolution so when
you look back what is money so money is
a form of communication so it
communicates value it's a way I can
store my value until I'm ready to deploy
that and then when I give it to you it
communicates how much value the thing
that you have right so this medium of
communication medium of exchange um and
throughout thousands of years of History
there's been lots of things that have
been Ane medium of exchange right some
shells feathers rocks gold Etc right and
so what happens is they typically follow
like this predictable path and so first
you start out as a collectible it's like
oh this is like pretty cool like let me
collect a couple of these things if that
if I say if if those collectibl become
big enough it could potentially evolve
into the next stage which would be
moving from a collectible to to a store
value right so you see the very wealthy
storing a lot of their value in
Collectibles Fine Art old cars things
like that right but now they've gone
from a collectible to a store of value
I'm storing my wealth there now maybe if
potentially if there's enough proper
attributes it could evolve to the next
stage which would be Ane medium exchange
cars will not be a good medium exchange
because in order to be a good medium
exchange you have to have certain
attributes so it needs to be portable
divisible durable recogniz able sellable
things like that right so a car wouldn't
work good because it's not really
divisible bananas wouldn't work good
because they're not um durable right
gold has work good because it's most of
those things but it's not very portable
right right so if potentially it meets
those it could go from a store value to
a medium of exchange and then if it's
successful at medium exchange and gets
enough adoption if it's recognizable
enough it could then move to a unit of
account that'd be the final stage so
it's sort of like this evolutionary
process and so I think that Bitcoin is
beats every other thing in the world at
the best attributes of moneyness so I
think we've already gone from the
collectible stage to the store value
stage I think everyone agrees to that
and I think we're already into not not
totally but we've already moved started
moving into the medium of Exchange Place
I mean El Salvador isn't is a prime
example of that as we already said
earlier lots of people that we both know
I'm sure live 100% on bitcoin so it is
working as that it's not widespread
enough so it's an evolutionary process
so probably you know over the next um
okay and then uh yeah so medium exchange
and I would say I'm looking at it in a
50-year cycle so I talked about the
fourth Industrial Revolution there's
been five technological revolutions so
far and they they're about every 50
years so I believe bit Bitcoin is the
sixth decentralized technology is the
6th and it's like a 50-year process so
we're you know 12 13 years in at this
point like give it another 15 20 years
so I think what will happen is we'll
continue to see more and more people use
it as a medium exchange that will
probably continue for another you know
the rest of the decade um and then we'll
start to see it becoming units of
account so right now most things are
priced in dollars right so when the
dollar was taken off the gold standard
so gold was the unit of account dollars
were measured by how many ounces of gold
they represented you're from the UK a
pound what does the pound pound of yeah
a pound of gold a pound sterling of
sterling silver right so precious metals
were the unit of account paper
referenced back to that now paper became
this unit of account but really what
they did is they said that under the
Petro dollar agreement that oil would be
the asset backing the paper um and so
the unit of account is where instead of
pricing things in dollars we're pricing
things in in whatever that new currency
is in in Bitcoin in SATs or something
like that so you said in 50 years you
think Bitcoin would be the you know well
I look at this as like this 50-year
cycle so I think I mean if I had to put
time frames on it I think probably by
the end of the decade I think it'll be
pretty widely recognized as a medium
exchange and you know everything that
we've spoken about um it's all about you
know taking the power back you know
protecting you know property rights
Liberty Freedom um you know protecting
ourselves against inflation tyranical
governments authoritarian governments so
and then I know we've also spoken about
the fact that they can't really stop
Bitcoin but it's still just I still just
wonder you know whether they could do
something to stop this because you know
this sounds like you know the uh quite
the opposite of a dystopian Future
Sounds like the uh Let's do let's do a
thought experiment there Utopia sounds
like perfect Utopia there you go that's
the word dystopia Utopia oh Utopia yeah
of course if Bitcoin is the you know the
unit of account and and we're all free
we have all these property rights
everything is great you know there's no
more inflation it sounds like the
perfect Utopia that they just would
never let happen we'll see experiment as
do it well the goal is to take away
their ability to stop that from
happening right right and so that's the
difference right so Libertarians want to
pass laws but laws are written by men
and men are always going to do this and
so if we understand the source of their
power is money and we take away that
that power then maybe they have no
chance to stop it but let's do a thought
experiment what are things the
government has tried to stop
successfully in the past let's just
let's just look through them so the US
has had a war on Obesity is does the US
have more obesity or less more but I
don't think they're really trying to
stop it okay they have a war on um drugs
they spent three trillion on drugs
what's the number one I still feel like
that they they injected drugs into the
system okay s I'm running all this go
they so they the the US government is
responsible for bringing fentanyl into
the country I don't actually so I
actually don't know enough about this um
but apparently maybe you know more and
you can tell me in the 80s I don't know
the US government is responsible for all
the what was it like cocaine in the Los
Angeles so that's I mean that's a little
story this and they helped the Mexicans
cartels it wasn't the Mexicans so it was
uh it was under the Iran Contra okay so
what was happening is the the CIA which
is like a rogue government o agency con
constantly trying to overthrow
governments right so that's a division
of the US government that is just like I
said Rogue and should just be shut down
they're dangerous um but they just
constantly throw around uh they they
constantly do illegal operations to
overthrow governments and during the
Iran Contra they wanted to overthrow the
government down in uh Iran or I'm sorry
in
Nicaragua but they couldn't do it
legally through the United States so
they did it illegally um so they needed
money so where are they going to get the
money well they got cocaine and they
brought it to Los Angeles and sold it in
Los Angeles and got the money and then
they took the money to Iran and bought
the weapons they brought the weapons
back to Nicaragua okay all right so they
that is true that's documented we know
that so they did bring some cocaine to
LA and sell it I don't think they're
bringing uh fentanyl into the country
okay and so the point of this is that
they've spent about $3 trillion do on
the War on Drugs but drugs are a bigger
problem today than they were before the
start of the war and think about drugs
drugs are physical meaning I have to
grow it I have to cultivate it I have to
process it package it ship it smuggle it
and then distribute it it's physical I
can catch you and find drugs on you how
do they stop stop something totally
digital mhm um what about the war on
terrorism terrorism is a much bigger
problem today than when they started the
war on terrorism so every time the
government tries to stop something with
a war on whatever it's only gotten
bigger and batter and worse and so the
other thing is like they spent $3
trillion to stop drugs and drugs are a
bigger problem today the number one
cause of death from 18 to35 is fentanyl
overdose they can't stop that and so
they can't even stop drug from being in
prison I mean the most secure place in
the world they can't even stop that so
if they can't stop something the
physical how do they stop something in
the digital and then you always have to
go back understanding Bitcoin is
difficult because you have to understand
a bunch of different disciplines one of
which is like understanding like uh
philosophy if you will but like human
incentives so for example when I tell
you that you shouldn't do drugs it
doesn't really make you want to do them
because you know they're dangerous if I
say don't do heroin it doesn't I'm going
to go do heroin because Mar told me not
to but if I say that you don't have a
right to store your wealth in a way that
I can't steal from you then it kind of
makes you want to do that which is why
every time they talk about putting new
measures against gun rights in the US
gun cells go through the roof every time
they talk about it people go buy guns
right and so if they triy to say hey you
don't have a right to store your wealth
that we can't steal from you then people
are going to want to do that so it
changes the incentives as well so I just
think it's it's just not going to be
possible now could they curtail it I
mean sure there's lots of people that
don't want to break the law right plenty
but there's a lot of people that do and
so there's plenty of people still going
to prison over drugs but most people
don't so I I guess potentially it could
slow down the adoption and I think I was
asked this on Gary Cardone show earlier
this week
what I think the biggest attack vectors
are and I said that I think the attack
Vector they're coming for Elizabeth
Warren is probably going to be in
conjunction with black rock and ETFs in
general and just say you can own Bitcoin
Bitcoin is not illegal but you own it
through ETF exact self custy is illegal
exactly that's what I think is the
attack Vector now what happens in that
case well the US still participates in
Bitcoin you and I can't hold it legally
technically maybe um but then back to
Game Theory well then just El Salvador's
got it yeah right or whatever yeah no
that's really interesting I no I also I
also have the same opinion um you can't
stop Bitcoin um but if that was the
attack Vector which they go for and they
make it illegal then I find it hard H
sorry illegal to hold um non kyc Bitcoin
then I find it difficult to imagine a
world where Bitcoin is you know the unit
of account just because they make it so
difficult but I definitely think that
Bitcoin is the future but I think it's
going to be controlled through major
institutions like Black Rock that's how
I they they can't force that right they
can't they can make a law they can say
we'll kill you if you don't hold it they
can do that but they can't do it for the
whole world right and so the more they
do that they'll only put problems on
themselves into a situation into a
system that's already crumbling and so
back to this 50-year experiment the
experiment's up like we have another
decade at best like this experiment over
so you have to think in long periods of
time the U the UK was the superpower
before the US the the um Sterling was
the global Reserve currency before the
US dollar the dollar did take that over
but it was about a 30 to 40e process
that happened so we have to start
thinking in terms of decades and not
years and so I think everyone's
expecting way too much too soon so if
you think okay well the US dollar took
over from the pound sterling over 30 or
40 years what happens in 20 years from
now and so I just think that things are
changing very rapidly I think you can
see it most people don't understand
where these changes actually lead to but
where these changes actually lead to is
technology has moved so fast the current
form of government we have is no longer
compatible the current form of
government that we have is dying in
their dying graphs like a caged animal
they're lashing out trying to hang on to
whatever power they have uh physics says
that every every um action has an equal
and opposite reaction so the more they
try to control the more entrepreneurs
try to set up systems to get out of it
the more people get out of it the more
they try to control but the more they
control more people move out of it the
more people move out of they try to
control and it's like a reinforcing
wheel and as they're dying as their
power continues to diminish as the money
printer continues to have diminishing
returns as new technology continues to
advance forward I think they just fall
further and further behind and so if I
think in decades or two decades I think
this whole system looks different the
world looks different well something
which is uh developing very fast is AI
um I don't know I don't know what your
opinions are actually on AI so feel free
to get into that but where do you think
Ai and Bitcoin meet um do you think it
would be add any value to bitcoin do you
think it would could be an issue for
Bitcoin what's your take on the
relationship between Bitcoin and AI one
thing that's uh interesting if I think
about where you know in decades right
Bitcoin is as I already said you know
borderless permissionless censorship
resistant IM mutable Bitcoin is also
person MH so what does that mean person
well that means that in order to get a
bank account you have to be a person you
have to prove that you you know you're a
person right but with Bitcoin you just
need a Bitcoin wallet address and you
can receive Bitcoin so in light of AI
and humans are no good at imagin the
future cuz all we can do is Imagine
better versions of what we have today
exactly what happens is when we get new
sets of building blocks we can build
things we hadn't imagined before so
that's why it never works out but let's
just think about what we could see so
you know we've heard a lot about um
Tesla's self-driving and potentially
doing like Airbnb or I mean Uber Uber on
their own right so like a car could
literally by AI could be like its own
thing right well that car could have its
own Bitcoin wallet so now you have a car
running on AI That's running its own
business that has its pays and sells it
makes its own Revenue profit and loss
whatever and it's not a person it's
person list Bitcoin could be person list
now was it Sam Alman with that worldcoin
was trying to solve that right he said
if you scan your retina you'll prove
you're a person that's what he was
trying to do prove you're a person
bitcoin's person list so I think there
could be some overlaps with Bitcoin and
AI um as far as AI goes I'm not really
uh I'm not a I'm not you know I'm not
really that deep into the Weeds on the
technology I would say kind of my
thoughts on it
are it has a lot of potential it's very
dangerous I don't think it's as scary
I'm not as scared of it as most people
seem to be I don't think it's as scary
and I know there's certainly two
different camps of this and some people
some of these people are way smarter
than me but I think I don't I don't see
AI as this threat that becomes smarter
than humans and destroys the world no I
don't see that there's two reasons why I
don't
uh the first reason why is because very
broadly speaking and again I'm not an
expert but I am a tech guy um there's
broadly speaking there's two types of AI
there's what we call narrow Ai and and
Broad or general AI so narrow AI is
where I train an AI on a very specific
task like play chess or play this video
game or drive this car now we've gotten
massive massive advancements in narrow
AI as we can see chat gbt or driving
cars and all these things massive
investment and it's and it's moving very
fast very fast but in general or broad
AI we've had almost no advancement now
about a about a year ago I got a sit
down with Naval nval ramicon and he's
like you know prolific Silicon Valley VC
and I asked him this specific question
and what he told me this is about a year
ago his mind might have changed
disclaimer but he said that for Broad
and general AI there's been almost no
advancement since the 70s oh wow okay
the human brain is so intricate and so
complex that we can't even comprehend
The Power of One Brain Cell It's so
massive and so complex and so we haven't
been able to figure out how to build an
AI that could have that much uh brain
power
capacity so that's like a technical side
the other reason people might not
appreciate this side but we all have
sort of this world view every one of us
has a lens that we world view the world
through I view the lens of the world um
as uh that we were created this isn't a
random world that we live in if you look
at the intricacies of the human body or
the world everything hangs on a Razor's
Edge if I took a Rolex watch and took it
completely apart and put into a box and
shook it for a 100 million years there's
no chance that watch goes perfectly back
together and it's on time there's no
chance of that and that's if I had all
the parts already there like this world
did not just randomly come together so I
believe it was created and I believe
that we are creative we have creative
capabilities and don't believe that a
machine can take take that over right um
I don't I don't believe a machine could
ever be as creative as that now ever is
a big term maybe in a thousand years or
something like that but um that's a
technical reason and that's sort of like
my worldview reason and so feel feel
free to disagree with that no no I
thought that was really interesting um
I've never heard someone talk about a
Rolex being shaken and being yeah that's
interesting way to put it um but so just
to go back as X so so how do you think
we're created you think we were like
purposely created by a god you think
that okay yeah for sure interesting
that's another podcast it's it's another
podcast yeah so for sure we could
certainly go down deep into that I think
um what's interesting is in the Bitcoin
space specifically you
see and more and more and more people
come to that realization because once
you start to like open up your mind and
really start to think deeply about these
things I mean it's just the natural
conclusion that you come to and at the
end of the day um I said there's kind of
two camps and the reason why there two
camps is we all have to have faith in
something I think it's ridiculous that a
God would create us well I think it's
ridiculous that we came from nothing
right we all have to believe something
that we don't really have um proof of
the question that I would ask and we can
put this on another podcast but like if
you think about it like okay so we
evolved yeah let's let's just chase that
down so we came from monkeys which came
from Omas which came from whatever
cool where did life come
from like how did something become alive
though there's no answer for that right
I've studied Evolution right so there's
there's there's no answer for that so
where did life actually come from even
if we did evolve now we can get into
Evolution so why aren't why don't we
still see species in some form of
evolution like where are the half monkey
half men like where are they anymore
right they're not still evolving like
that's pretty interesting but where did
life come from and there's no answer for
that and if you anyway so that's a whole
another conversation yeah no I love it
we'll have to have that conversation I
talk about that actually a lot with my
brother we talk about Evolution and and
where everything comes from um but let's
just finish on crypto for a second where
do you think um how do you see the next
two years playing out I'm just going to
say one thing real quick too you know
like um in in our um in the United
States Constitution
talks about inable rights god-given
inable rights and so going kind of going
back to be a freedom maximalist like I
believe in what our founding fathers
believed in which is god-given
inalienable rights so our rights were
not given to us by men men do not have
the power to control us or give us
freedom God gave us these rights and um
the Constitution was set up to control
the government from infringing on those
rights not giving us rights but keep
them from taking the natural god-given
rights and so if you don't believe in
that then where do we think then then
you would also believe that we don't
have rights then rights were given to us
by men so anyway different worldview but
anyway it's interesting no I appreciate
that it's interesting um no I just want
to get your take on the next two years
and how it's going to look in the market
yeah
so let's let's start talking about where
we'll be in two years from now and then
we'll talk about how we get there okay
all right so I think um the reason why I
say that is I think the longer we look
out um the easier it is to sort of
understand where things are but we don't
know the trials and tribulations from
there um I think before we recorded we
were talking about your workouts or
whatever right so let's say that like um
I had a goal that I wanted to put on 20
lbs of muscle so I'm going to change my
workouts I'm going to change my diet do
all these things and I know that if I
increase my calorie intake by 25% for
the next two years I'll put on 20 pounds
so I know if I do this every day for 20
years I'll get to that goal but where
will I be in three months I don't really
know where will I be in 9 months I'm not
really sure but I'm pretty sure in 2
years if I right right and so like the
longer time frame helps us a little bit
so let's start with that so if we
understand some of the constraints that
we have so we already talked about one
are the government's printing more money
or less are we talking about from a
financial standpoint okay let's talk
about from money side first we can talk
about Freedom later so from a money side
yeah sure so um if you understand math
and you understand the natural
constraints of math and the fiscal
situation we have in the United States
and the governments of the world the ECB
the Euro um the boj China right now I
mean it's just crazy um they have to
continue printing more money because
we're in a debt-based monetary system
what that means we already talked about
money is created through debt issuance
what that means is dollars are
liabilities and the debt is the asset
and if you understand that then the
asset is what's the collateral to get
more debt
so then all of our system is built on
collateral stacked on collateral stacked
stacked on um stacked on collateral if
the valuations of that collateral starts
to drop then margin calls are required
and then the whole system collapses if
you think about the world being
controlled
by let's call it the bankers and the
corporations they don't want to lose
control of that they can't allow that
system to collapse so we have to keep it
propped up we're in a Ponzi scheme so we
have to keep propping that up we know
just in the US um government for example
again we have to print or we have to
borrow 50% of our budget and that's only
getting worse um and so we have to keep
printing money there's just no way
around it
I believe that we'll see um at least
double digit inflation probably for the
rest of the decade MH and will they be
honest about that because no of course
not no and it'll it'll come in waves so
inflation will ramp up and go back down
so like for example in the 1940s we saw
inflation go up to 19% and then Nega -2
and then back up to 18 and then zero and
then back up to 16 like so I think we'll
see it's going to be like this um but I
think the big Trend and that's why I say
further out because it's going to be so
wavy it's hard to know exactly where
we'll be in 6 months or 9 months but I
think in 2 or 3 years home prices are up
50% gas prices are up
50% um pretty much all assets will be up
you know 50% at least in the next two or
three years because of that so I think
that's where we're at um that's why when
everyone's talking about oh my God the
housing Market's going to collapse and I
bought a house two years ago and Mark
you're an idiot you're buying at the top
of the market and blah blah blah it's
like it's G don't you know it's going to
be cut in half I don't care yeah cuz in
30 years from now it's going been worth
a lot more right um so I think um in two
or three years from now everything
things up 50% or more because of the
massive amount of money printing that we
have to uh print now how do we get from
here to there um I think this year going
into 2024 right now uh 2023 is closed
depends on when recording comes out but
um everyone's been predicting this
recession and this market crash since
2022 and then 20 don't you know when the
FED raises rates that stocks have to
repic they have to repic down don't you
know when mortgage rates go from 0 to 8%
that home prices have to they have
they've had to for two years and they
haven't mhm right so um 2023 is in the
books the quarter's done a recession
would be two quarters and so we don't
have two quarters left I think we're
good through q1 of next year 2024 and
then we'll see what happens right now
the Market's sort of pricing in some Fed
rate Cuts starting in March or April of
next year and typically that is not a
good sign they're typically cutting
because things are already getting so
bad so it's possible that we have um a
recession which could lead to some asset
price deflation we'll call it that so
weakness in the stock market the home
prices things like that um but I think
whatever we see will be pretty moderate
in my opinion but this isn't a good
thing so what I'm actually predicting is
the opposite of what most people think
most people are afraid you talked about
earlier on the sidelines because there's
this big crash coming I think there's a
crash coming too but it's different than
what most people think so most people
are are afraid of a crash because their
standard of living will go down if I
lose my job and I have to take a lower
paying job if my sponsors don't pay me
as much if my retirement account goes
down I have to lower the quality of my
life I have to move to a smaller house I
can't go out to eat as much things like
that right so a crash then we would say
is my standard of living goes down but
what I think is the opposite of that but
it's the same result so I think there's
a crash coming but instead of a
deflationary crash it's an inflationary
crash and that means that prices move up
so fast I still can't afford my standard
of living because home prices went up so
much I can't afford the same house
because food price went up I can't
afford to go out to eat so much so the
result is the same it's still a crash
but it's it went up instead of down mhm
now it's there's a couple big
differences within that so so let's just
say I think that's what we're facing
over the next couple years which is why
home price all those things go up I
think potentially we could see weakness
going into 2024 except for that we have
an election year right no incumbent
president has ever won in a recession
okay all right so that's sort of what
happened with Trump they sort of crashed
the market right going into that
election so
if the Democrats want to win if they
want to stay in power if which I think
they do um and if they sort of control
the market which they kind of do then
they're going to do everything in their
power to make sure there's not a
recession this yearh right so we have
that going for us um and I think the
other thing is that people don't realize
how the the fed and the central banks
around the world have changed how they
work in the market since 2008 so
everyone's like oh but Mark look at 1970
and look at 1940 and look at 19 19 29
the FED wasn't interacting in the
markets like they do today so in 2008 we
they started quantitative easing it was
the first time we've seen that and so
now like in in um in 2008 it took seven
months after bar Stern's collapse which
was like the bank that collapsed that
triggered the great uh the great
financial crash it took the FED seven
months to come up with any type of
program when the banks capped in 2023 it
took them six days mhm right when in
2008 the markets crashed 65% in 2020
they crashed 30% yeah and they and in 20
2008 it keep took seven years years to
come back in 2020 it took 6 months MH
and so if it happens again I think it
goes down by 15% and it comes back in 3
months and instead of $1 trillion in 08
instead of $10 trillion in 2020 it'll be
$20 trillion M so I think there could be
a potential little crash I think they'll
probably overreact blow skyh High that's
why I don't know exactly where that fits
like month by month kind of a thing I
think 2024 to me um looks like a
stagflationary period meaning High
inflation and low economic growth so
people continue to get further and
further behind maybe your pay goes up a
little bit but prices are moving up
faster and so everyone's standard living
is going down nothing really crashes
nothing really grows it's not good now a
deflationary crash would be better
because what it does is it rips the
Band-Aid off and now Millennials can buy
houses and they can buy stocks at good
prices but the problem that I think
we're having is that we're not going to
get that good entry and if you don't get
in now you're only going to fall further
further behind like everyone thinks that
the housing market has to crash who's
going to be able to pay these prices
with these crazy mortgage rates well 40%
of the homes are owned in pure cash mhm
and most of the homes being bought today
are being bought with 50% down payments
because people have cash because they've
owned a home so if you own a home you
can sell that and buy another home if
you don't own a home it's very difficult
to get in and I think that problem just
continues to get worse so what about
Bitcoin then do you think that the um do
you think that the haring's already
priced in how do you see Bitcoin playing
out over the next two years no it's
certainly not priced in you know um I
mean when I say it's not priced in it's
priced in for where it needs to be at
this time so people are front running it
um you know looking at just you know
Bitcoin having cycle history I mean it
looks like we'll be at $150,000 of
Bitcoin is that your prediction for the
is that your all-time high prediction
for this cycle I I typically don't try
to make these predictions I I don't I
don't even really think them think them
through so I don't want to make them
because I haven't really looked at the
charts and really try to think it
through but I think yeah I think 150,000
seems pretty conservative pretty
conservative for this I think think
getting to a million dollars by the end
of the decade seems more likely really
the decade yeah I think by the end of
the decade a million dollars but you
have to also understand that a million
dollars doesn't mean much at that point
right exactly in Zimbabwe everybody
became a billionaire but it was 350
billion for one egg yeah yeah it's
ridiculous so crazy so like something
like that right so it's like U even
today a million is not like when I was a
kid a millionaire was like a big deal
and now a million is like barely I mean
in California you make a million dollars
half goes to the state so you end up
with $500,000 000 in my town the median
us or the median price of a home in my
town is 1.6 million so you just get the
median home price of 1.6 million you
have two kids in school and then you
have two brand new cars you make car
payments on you're broke yeah you're not
in a middle class anymore like you're
broke at a million dollars it's crazy
yeah it's unbelievable what's
interesting is um the cost of living in
general is way more in America than it
is in the UK that's one thing that's
that really sort of surprised me um just
just moving here the cost of living is
much higher here um well you're in Miami
too yeah yeah of course but just in the
in the states in general um but then the
but then the the salary is higher here
as well like you earn more here there is
more opportunity um that's just
something which has fascinated me since
being here um because a million dollar a
million pound house at home that's like
that's a that's like a big deal that's
like a nice house you know whereas here
it's like can't really get much well
there's plenty of places in Florida
where a million dooll home still is
really nice okay right and you can move
to Middle America Missouri or Kansas and
or you know whatever Oklahoma there a
million dollars buys you yeah but in
London like you can get a you can get
like a really nice house for like $2
million whereas like here not in Miami
exactly which is so fascinating to me
that that's been really interesting so
what are you what are you working on
now what about all the lizard people
we're going to talk about oh my God you
know what I I had I had David Ike on the
show and um because obviously he's the
guy behind that theory and uh they took
it down and I got a strike oh really so
uh yeah you know Mark you know I'm I
have my opinions and I'm I I'm just uh
deciding on what opinions I wish to
share these days yeah I was just kidding
no but seriously I'm just very
calculated more calculated these days
than I than I you have to be
unfortunately I I remember the first day
um that I found myself censoring my what
I was going to talk about on YouTube and
I I can still remember the feeling of
just like I can't believe it's come to
this WOW but it is what it is right
we're we're in somebody else's sandbox
and I guess we have to play by the rules
I guess I will add as well there's
another reason to sense yourself it's
not just like getting uh censored by
YouTube and things like that it's also
just like playing the game you know like
you don't have to not everybody has to
know your opinion on everything oh yeah
for sure you know so that's something
I've learned recently as well yeah no I
just thought we're going to talk about
some other topics but um what am I
working on so um a bunch of things so
one creating as much much content as I
can which I think I'm going to try to
pull back on some of that in 2024 it's
just gotten a little bit too much for me
um so I could focus more on business
stuff um so I have the nashy syndicator
radio show on iHeart I got the podcast I
got the YouTube channel um I'm putting
out about six hours of content a week
just in that alone plus going on other
shows things like that that's a lot um I
have like education courses and and a
newsletter that I write um in the
investment space um I've been doing over
last couple years a lot of uh I've been
doing my own events Market disruptors
live um I've been doing uh some really
high ticket coaching um so I've been
doing that um and lately I've taken some
Equity positions in some companies that
actively working in and helping them
grow um I'm I've been an investor and
adviser for over a decade and I um I'm
an advisor and an investor in TVP
Channel Venture Partners which is a
venture capital Fund in the Bitcoin
space I'm a partner in the Bitcoin
opportunity fund which is a new
investment uh vehicle for the Bitcoin
space as well we just did a couple big
deals we did a deal with um Jack dorsy
just did a new Bitcoin mining pool so we
were one of the key investors in that
deal so we've done a couple deals there
so trying to help the ecosystem grow I'm
a big believer in building the world
that you want MH right and a lot of
times people in the Bitcoin space
specifically think they can just go buy
their Bitcoin and go hoddle and like the
whole world's going to change but it's
like not like that so like um I believe
in building the world that we want so
like with these funds we're really
trying to get money and deploy it to
build this world right to like build
this ecosystem to one day be able to use
it as a medium exchange um doing that
and then speaking a lot which I think
I'm going to try and slow my speaking
down in 2024 as well uh yeah so content
education uh coaching and then and then
investing in building yeah you're doing
a million things every time I see you
you're you're you're working on a
million different things um you told me
yesterday you you're be building a house
in Mexico like there's just a lot going
on I got I built a I built a house in uh
Texas outside of Austin a ranch acreage
property I got five cows and eight goats
and donkeys and like that's sort of like
my bugout spot maybe if I need it if I
had get out of California then I got the
place in Mexico going as well so just
trying to build options you know the
world is uncertain and we beat
uncertainty with optionality and so just
trying to build as many options as we
can that's amazing where can people find
you and get in touch with you I'm not
hard to find uh just search Mark Moss
onmark moss.com is my my my
website I got locked out of my Twitter
account four months ago and I've been
out yeah some hacker got in and and
changed my
tofa and uh you're not on Twitter I
haven't been for four months wow yeah
it's someone took over my account and
posted a bunch of like nft crypto stuff
on there and I've been able to get in so
um what are you doing about it I've
filled out like 30 support requests and
nothing and they uh keep charging me my
eight bucks every single month and they
just won't respond to my support tickets
so uh that kind of sucks um but uh
hopefully I'll be back soon yeah I've
start I mean I've been trying to connect
everybody I met somebody last night at
the at the party who says oh I know
someone on Twitter I'll get you turn
back you start again why have you
started a new
Twitter we we'll repost you and tell
everyone to follow you what do you mean
like yeah no I mean I could you know I
don't know I I I don't know I don't know
I mean if you care enough I that's what
I would do in the meantime well I I
think I'm going to get it back I mean
I've talked to many people who know
people inside but in the meantime but in
the meantime just grow it and then you
have it as a backup in case you know
anything was to happen again I don't
know I so as a content creator going
back to kind of like um self-censoring
things like that like G getting your
platforms taken from you was like the
worst thing that could happen it's
really disheartening yeah and
um part of another project I'm an
advisor investor for Zion is sort of
trying to build uh a new platform that's
built on bitcoin and lightning um and
like I just thought I don't want to
build another platform on somebody
else's platform if I'm going to build
another platform I'll go do it on Noster
I'll go do it on Zion if I'm going to
build another platform I'll do it there
so I'm kind of like if if Twitter if I
can't get my Twitter account back then
screw Twitter I think I'm over it yeah
do that make sense this was like a this
is like a like divine intervention
telling you you know time it's time to
be done with these centralized platforms
yeah because like so then so then I'll
spend another couple years building up
another one and they'll take that from
me too like and and they didn't take it
from me a hacker just went and changed
my freaking password and they just won't
even respond to like change my password
back so I don't know part of me is just
like if I can't get it back then I'm
probably just going to be over it yeah I
don't know all right well I hope you get
it back yeah me too you know um but Mark
thank you so much if you know anybody in
Twitter hit me up yeah yeah exactly
exactly um I I'll ask around for you
I'll see what I what I can do I didn't
know that that happened so that sucks um
but I'll definitely try and help mark
thank you so much for coming on it's
always such a pleasure um I always learn
so much from you so um yeah I really
appreciate you coming on thank you good
time guys make sure you follow Mark
always so much interesting content he's
putting out there's always so much to
learn from Mark and guys if you did
enjoy this podcast then please don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe as we have a lot more content
coming we'll see you next week